un bien bel anniversaire à fêter les
cinq ans des révélations des panamas
papers des découvertes impressionnante
sur l'évasion fiscale à travers le monde
orchestrée depuis le panama plus de 370
journalistes de 76 pays regroupés au
sein d'un consortium avait enquêté sur
11,5 millions de documents divulgués par
un lanceur d'alert des archives du
cabinet d'avocats panaméen maussac
fonséca qui a domicilié plus de deux
cent quatorze mille sociétés offshore
entre 1977 et 2015
rien que ça 140 personnalités politiques
fortes éclaboussé en arabie saoudite en
argentine aux émirats arabes unis au
royaume uni en ukraine en chine en
france pour ne citer que ces pays des
fortunes du showbiz du sport et même des
trafiquants criminels et terroristes
fürth épinglés après cette déflagration
que s'est il passé
des manifestations contre les dirigeants
fraudeurs ont essaimé à travers le monde
le ministre de l'industrie espagnol josé
manuel soria a dû démissionner le
premier ministre islandais david greene
logson s'est lui aussi démis mais
rassurez vous il est ensuite devenu
député
or milieux politiques seul un avocat
uruguayen a dû renoncer à ses fonctions
circulez ya rien à voir certaines
banques ont été inquiété comme la
deutsche bank dont les locaux ont été
perquisitionnés en l'allemagne en 2018
en france la société générale la bnp le
crédit agricole ont été accusés de
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale des
auditions oui mais pas de condamnation
et quid de maussac fonséca rien ou
presque une dizaine de bureaux du
cabinet panaméen ou fermées dans le
monde
les deux fondateurs et organes maussac
et ramon fonséca ont brièvement est
incarcéré mais pour une autre affaire
celle de l'opération la baja tôt au
brésil ils font depuis octobre 2020
l'objet d'un mandat d'arrêt européen
mais ils dorment toujours paisiblement
ramon fonseca sperme et mène sur twitter
de fustiger la mafia d'extrême gauche et
de défier les autorités allemandes
merci pensez vous que l'allemagne ait le
droit de parler de justice alors que les
tribunaux de nuremberg ont condamné et
exécuté seulement 14 nazi du haut
commandement puis de 50 millions de
personnes sont mortes y compris toute sa
population juive ce pays
pas de punition mais est ce qu'au moins
lama n'a été recouvrée en 2015 françois
hollande s'était félicité des
révélations des panamas papers
anticipant de réjouissantes rentrées
fiscales toutes les informations qui
seront livrés donneront lieu à des
enquêtes des services fiscaux et à des
procédures judiciaires
6500 contribuables ont été poursuivis
pour fraude fiscale en 2018 les pays
concernés ont récupéré un milliard
d'euros dans 225 millions pour le
royaume uni
154 millions pour l'allemagne et 120
millions pour la france
après 500 contrôles fiscaux pour 415
fraudeurs potentiels
les panama papers ont-ils donné lieu à
davantage de régulation
oui et non à la suite des révélations 39
pays s'étaient engagés à assurer
davantage de transparence sur les
sociétés actives à l'international
mais trois ans plus tard selon
transparancy international
plus de la moitié d'entre eux n'ont pas
respecté leurs engagements une
convention multilatérale contre la
fraude fiscale a été signé par 108 états
pour rendre les échanges d'informations
fiscales automatique mais pas par les
états unis
alors que l'état du deleware est
fréquemment dénoncés comme un paradis
fiscal
enfin personne n'oubliera l'assassinât
de la journaliste maltaise daphné
carvena gallizia exécutant 2017 alors
qu'elles enquêtaient sur des
personnalités politiques de malte dont
deux sont cités dans les panama papers
sept martyrs supposée des révélations
sur la corruption financière en dit long
sur les dangers encourus par les
lanceurs d'alert il reste peu protégés
malgré une directive européenne de 2018
alors que l'inertie dans le combat
contre l'évasion fiscale reste elle
toujours aussi colossal